We just launched support Peterson,
research.com a crowdfunding campaign to
pay for Professor Jordan Peterson is
academic research.
And then the first 24 hours we raised
more than an entire year's worth of
research funding for them.
That's amazing.
We did this because for the first time
in his 20 year career,
the government agency that hands out
research grants rejected his funding
proposal,
which just coincidentally came after he
made headlines for fighting against
political correctness.
Well what a poetic victory.
We're getting him that funding after all
and now he's more independent than ever.
Thanks very much for doing this.
Hey,
it's working in an extraordinarily well.
I've been sitting here,
I'm down in Boston,
I'm going to do a talk at Harvard and a
on political correctness and access
compassion and free speech.
And I've been sitting here watching the
numbers climb and I think there's more
than 1500 people who are supporting my
research now.
And we've gone past for first year of
funding already and I guess we're going
to try it for the second year.
Um,
it's remarkable.
And,
uh,
well I,
I,
I don't know what to say except my
graduate students are extraordinarily
happy about this because it solves their
problem.
Then we'll continue our research and can
just review that briefly.
Um,
the research is aimed first of all at
improving the accuracy of the
measurement of personality and we've
done some of some of that already.
Freaking the big five down into 10 sub
components.
So for example,
we've looked at the relationship,
the subcomponents of conscientiousness
and broken it down into industriousness
and orderliness and associated with
orderliness,
with disgust,
sensitivity and look its role in
increasing the probability of
conservative beliefs.
And we've looked at trade agreeableness
and compassionate in particular and
examine its relationship to politically
correct leaf because it has,
it seems to play a very strong role in
determining a proclivity for people to
adopt politically correct for leafs.
And we'll continue that and also
continue doing the basic research into
the development of programs like the
self authoring suite.
Uh,
the future authoring portion of that has
already been demonstrated to raise
college students,
grades five,
about 25% decrease the dropout.
And we've got 1200 high school students
lined up to try a high school version of
that in the fall.
And we're very much looking forward to
seeing if we can duplicate our success
with that.
Anyways,
it's quite remarkable.
So,
um,
I'd like to thank everybody thoroughly
for supporting this research and,
and supporting me.
I find it amazing that if this is
possible even,
and so,
um,
our way we go I guess,
and once again thank you to,
to you and to everyone that's supporting
the research over to you as rough,
we'll see how it goes over the next,
I guess we're gonna run this for a
month.
We'll see how it goes over the month,
next month.
We've got lots of plans in the loud.
So,
um,
I think we can put the money to very
good use and use.
That will be,
what would you say?
It's not only scientifically valid,
but hopefully that will have a broad
scale impact on practically speaking
because as a clinical psychologist,
I like to conduct research that's going
to be abroad practical benefit as well
as theoretical and scientific utility.
So anyways,
thanks again already.
It is amazing and thank you to all of
you.
All the net proceeds will be sent to
Professor Peterson.
And remember the perks,
if you give $100 you'll receive a link
to an exclusive video from him.
$250 get you an invitation to a
reception to meet him and his Grad
students and a thousand dollar donor.
Well,
you'll actually get a bound copy of his
research personally autographed.
So let's go forward.
Let's set our sights on the stretch goal
of funding the second year of his
recent,
remember it was a five year application
that it was rejected.
So let's do what the politicians and the
bureaucrats won't visit.
www.support peterson,
research.com support free speech and
academic freedom.
Go to support Peterson research.com.